Good morning, every-nyang.
Good morning.
Hello.
Hold on, I'm trying to fix my...
I'm trying to fix the window capture.
It looks so ugly.
Why is it...
Since when did...
Wait a second.
Since when did YouTube videos not...
Why is it not a perfect square?
Since when were the YouTube videos curved?
Maybe it's fine.
I'll get smaller once it starts.
Move your head.
It hasn't started yet!
I'll move my head once it starts.
Gosh.
It's been like that for a while.
Oh my god.
I didn't even notice.
Big head in the way.
I'll move my head.
I'll move my head once it starts.
Good morning, everybody.
Did I say it already?
Hello.
I'm awake.
I'm a little sick.
I'm hoping for Tomodachi Life 2.
That's all that I have to say.
I'm gonna turn on the sound.
Let's put on some music until it begins.
There might be like overlapping BGM.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
What time is it?
Oh, we still have four minutes.
Yeah.
Let's put on a little bit so it's not just silence.
Because I'm just sitting here in silence.
Tomodachi Life 2.
Your head's not in the way.
It's huge though.
Stop making fun of my head.
It holds lots of secrets, okay?
I'm trying to set up.
I just got on my computer like just now.
Okay, I have it open.
As you can see, I have the direct open.
You'll be able to hear it and watch it.
So if you have it open yourself, you can close it now.
I'm just kidding.
Unless you want.
Oops.
Let me move it over a little bit too.
Here.
We'll have it like a TV in the maid cafe.
Hell yeah.
Oh, you know secrets?
Name all of them.
Secret one, secret two, secret three, secret four, secret five, secret six.
I caught him in stream.
Yippee.
I forgot I remembered while you were offline one day.
Well, thank you.
Appreciate you sticking around.
I mean, I was going to say, please don't I remember.
Now that you remembered.
Now that you re-membered.
But like you remember, but like you remembered.
Words are hard.
Oh gosh, I'm so tired.
I just woke up like 10 minutes ago.
Wow.
What are you guys hoping for?
What is your hopes and your dreams, everybody?
I saw a lot of Silksong, which we're all on that hard copium, aren't we?
Who here just woke up?
Me.
Fire Emblem.
Tomodachi Life.
Xenoblade.
Silksong.
Tomodachi Life.
Ride or die, baby.
I mean, I'm already dead.
Ace Combat.
I think Vince is a member of the Lali Lule Lo.
No.
I hope they announce a game called Mint Phantom Super meets Super Mario.
I'm tired.
That's me right now.
I have no expectations.
I know nothing.
I'm just here for a good time.
Feet to where your head is huge.
Can we not?
Welcome to the Silksong disappointment area.
Nintendo Direct.
How much time?
Oh, one minute left, everybody.
One minute left.
Metal Gear Solid 6.
Only on the Switch.
Yeah, that's what they'll announce today.
100%.
I know.
It was leaked to me and my brain.
The aliens.
They beamed it directly in.
First stream after finding you from Clips.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
I know you watch Vinny, but have you seen him?
I mean Joel watching YouTube vids of some of your ghost cousins.
Joel?
Like, I don't think so.
Joel.
I have not.
My ghost cousins.
Oh my god.
That's my alarm.
Shut up.
When I think of Joel, I think of him.
Joel, I think I have Joel... What's his name?
Joel Haver or whatever.
He always makes funny skits, so I watch his channel.
Turn off the sound!
Oh my god, it's kinda loud.
Yippee!
Let's go!
Nintendo Direct, baby!
Princess Peach!
Luigi!
Did he just speak?
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Luigi game!
Wait, is this... this is...
Is this new Mario voice?
But it doesn't sound so new.
Mario and Luigi!
Yahoo!
Oh my gosh, look at them spin.
Spinning in tandem.
Wow, look at him go!
Oh my god, so cute!
Connie!
Too cute.
Wait.
Okay.
I feel less... less self-conscious reacting because before in the past, if I had to do a watch-along, I had no audio.
It was just me talking.
And so now it's not just me in silence.
Wow, Peach!
You can't both be in love with Peach.
That's weird.
Connie's so cute.
Mario and Luigi...
Brothership!
Hello, everyone.
I'm Shinya Takahashi, and I'll be your guide for today's Nintendo Direct.
That was the first new entry in the Mario and Luigi series in almost nine years.
No way!
Mario and Luigi Brothership.
Maybe they should have rethought the name.
Please look forward to a seafaring adventure that unfolds across mysterious islands, as well as evolved bros moves with Mario and Luigi.
Bros moves.
Okay, let's see the first batch of highlights.
Oh, I'm crying.
You know what's so funny is on the side, like under the recommended for me, five years ago, Silksong announcement trailer.
The thrill of the Nintendo World Championships is heading to the Nintendo Switch system.
Oh.
The thrill!
Take on over 150 speedrunning challenges from across 13 NES games.
From lightning-fast beats to action-packed battles.
Poppin' wheelies!
Familiarize yourself with each challenge and perfect your timing.
Then give it your best shot and aim for the top of the online leaderboards.
Oh, no.
You'll see Minthe Phantom on there.
It'll be an imposter.
Like completing Super Mario Brothers in one go.
Using warp pipes.
Stuck on a legend challenge?
Check out classified information for handy tips and tricks to help you improve.
It looks like retro.
Like even the guide.
Where you'll race against ghost data of players worldwide.
Back to the trail, half of the players will be eliminated.
You've only got one shot to survive.
Will you be the last one standing?
Nintendo World Championships NES Edition.
Launches on Nintendo Switch July 18th.
It's literally a speedrunning game.
Pre -orders for the digital version are available now on Nintendo Wii Shop.
A deluxe set containing a physical version of the game and other bonus items is also available for pre-order.
Wow!
Oh my gosh, the collector set.
The final battle of Fairy Tail is about to begin.
Fairy Tail?
One more time!
Happy!
Oh my god, Rie Kugumiya!
Relive the climactic Alvarez Empire arc.
An anime fairy tale in this action RPG.
What?
Set in the vast kingdom of Fiore, Team Natsu prepares to finish their fight.
I was gonna say, this isn't a Warriors-type game, is it?
Koei Tetsuo.
Fairy Tail 2.
Oh, I like her.
I don't remember her name though.
The red-haired girl.
Oh...
It starts with an E, right?
Erza.
Fairy Tail 2!
Anime!
The Icarus Uprising remaster, let's go.
So, Final Fantasy.
Final Fantasy.
FANTAZION!?
Final Fantasy?
Wow.
To restore his memories, Leo must confront an evil entity threatening all mankind.
There's eggs everywhere.
Vincent?
HAHAHA!
So, skills are the ticket to winning battles.
Nier Fantasies.
Yeah, looks like...
I thought Nier at first too.
Adjust a speed trajectory to target multiple enemies at once.
Come on, N каждый!
You can also send enemies you've encountered to a separate dimension and fight them later.
Is that how you spell dimension?
It's not a dimension, it's a Dimension.
Not the Dimension, though.
The Dimension Dungeon.
I still haven't played this though.
BEEBALL!
Sorry.
Just watching the lady so casually dribbling.
So funny.
Yeah!
Shoot, lady!
Keep going!
Woo!
You're killing it!
Oh no.
I can feel myself raging from that already.
She shoots!
She scores!
Swish swish, baby.
Alright.
We ballin'.
We ballin', Minto!
Men could never be ballin' like this.
Shut the heck up.
I was in basketball before.
Woah.
What is this?
But it looks kind of like...
The music is nice.
I like it.
It's one ugly looking thing.
I think it's kinda cute!
It's like...
It's got some nice hair.
Mio!
Memories in orbit.
What?
That's it?
We're just not gonna address that.
We're just gonna...
Everybody, we didn't even watch that.
That was a fever dream.
Dios mio.
Disney game.
What?
What big secret lies at the end?
Start sleuthing, because this free update launches on Nintendo Switch later today.
Okay.
Cool.
Hello kitty!
Where's my baby?
Where is he?
I'm scanning everywhere.
Customize your character.
Oh my god, stop.
So cute.
I love not Animal Crossing.
Let's go!
There he is!
And that is the main adventure in this open world adventure.
Son of a...
You must leave this house to solve mysteries and restore Friendship Island when...
Where is he?
Hello Kitty Island Adventure launches as a timed console exclusive...
Oh my god!
Why are they...
Look how tiny he is!
Oh god, he's so small!
Let's get loony in this wacky sports game.
What?
Play as Bugs Bunny, Daffy Duck, Porky Pig, and more across four arcade-style sports.
Unleash the...
We are balling today.
What is going on?
But watch out for falling anvils.
Looney Tunes wacky world sports...
What is this Space Jam?
Nintendo Switch this fall.
But it's not Space Jam.
That's all, folks.
Let's see if you can beat me in Game On.
Why does he sound like he's stuck in a...
Oh no.
New crewmate and imposter roles are being added to Among Us.
Phantom?
Excuse me, where's my royalties?
Plan tracking devices on others as a tracker.
Or turn invisible while taking out players...
What?
Suss things out when this free update for Among Us sneaks onto Nintendo Switch later today.
Wait, but it's only for the Switch?
It's only for the Switch?
This is Felicidad.
Felicidad!
Those who command and raise them are called Farmagia and play a vital role in the land...
It looks... is this the artist for Fairy Tail?
A farmagia must rise up against the oppressive magus...
To stop his vicious reign of the underworld.
Raise monsters and lead them into the fight against the magus' army.
Plant seeds...
Then cultivate them...
And harvest them to make your buddies come to life.
I'm growing dogs?
What is going on?
Make them then be trained for battle.
Fairy Tail 3, let's go!
Oh my god, look at this whole army!
It's like Pikmin-esque.
Weaknesses in action-packed combat.
Felicidad has blessed you!
To call forth a giant fusion summon.
And wreak havoc on your foes.
A horse is just standing still.
What is going on?
In Farmagia...
The Magus.
Launching on Nintendo Switch November 1st.
Farmagia.
The Magus.
Ok, cool.
Donkey Kong!
DK!
Punch him in the face!
It looks good.
It's kind of like triggering me though that they weren't like taking out all the...
Oh my gosh, it looks so cool!
They weren't taking out all the spikes, you know?
They weren't clearing it out.
Should have cleaned it up.
The original version had some awful motion controls.
I mean, that's just the Wii, right?
Monkey!
One of Donkey Kong and Diddy Kong's jungle escapades returns in HD.
Plenty of wild actions and antics are in store with these Kongs.
Look at this little Nintendo hat.
Jungle.
The time is nigh.
I thought it was Zelda for a second.
Tokyo Metropolitan Symphony Orchestra!
Wow, thank you for your service.
Dragon Quest?
Wait, it's actually Dragon Quest?
That's why I wouldn't know.
Journey with allies.
To face the Archfiend.
On an epic adventure.
Dragon Quest makes me so sad now though.
Memorable encounters.
It looks good though.
It looks really good.
Perplexing challenges.
And formidable monsters await.
Wow!
Iconic RPG.
Remade in HD 2D.
HD 2D is such a funny...
It looks so like...
The sprites look so fluent.
Forge your own path.
Go share the experience with your friends.
The legacy begins.
What's a good Dragon Quest to start?
Dragon Quest 3.
HD 2D Remake.
Coming to Nintendo Switch November 14th.
None of them.
Stop!
Eleven.
Eight.
I saw someone say three.
Oh?
Oh my god!
They totally bait and switched us!
It's all three of them!
Nintendo.
Hello.
Cute.
So cute.
This is where the fun part starts.
One day, we're going to be in a place...
where we can praise our power.
The power of...
the having it!
You know, The power of the darkness!
The power of light.
You know what?
It is not very long at all...
but I'm going to do my best.
Yes!
Interesting.
Awww, thank you!
Three, one, and two in that order is what he said.
ViviCore, thanks for the five giftings!
Like Metal Gear...
No...
What is going on?
Oh my god!
This is a game to rival Fortnite!
No way!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, no!
Is that Chucky?
Oh my god!
Spooky silly!
I love spooky!
Okay, spooky?
Spooky!
It's Luigi!
Hello?
Goofy ghosts!
Excuse me!
I don't like this game.
I'm feeling targeted right now.
Luigi's Mansion 2 HD!
Lots of Luigi today!
You pervert!
Luigi!
Why would you scream?
Dream, you're the one who...
Dempaman?
What?
Local co-op.
Free?
Okay.
I'm setting my July.
Dang, it's June.
What?
Oh no, tower defense.
Oh no.
Tower defense with anime movies.
And tactical tussles.
Metal slug tower defense.
You can also slug it out with other players in online battles.
Uh oh.
Metal slug attack reloaded.
Storms onto the Nintendo Switch system later today.
Oh no.
Uh oh.
Embark on an expedition of the damned in this eagerly awaited sequel to the Gothic roguelike RPG.
Oh, Darkest Dungeon 2.
Board your stagecoach and set off across...
I've never played Darkest Dungeon though.
...to prevent an apocalypse.
Fight off nightmarish fiends in turn-based combat.
And upgrade your abilities after each deadly run.
Darkest Dungeon 2 launches on Nintendo Switch July 15.
Hello.
Hello, Solidus.
Viewers begin later today on Nintendo eShop.
More classic titles are on the way.
Plus expansion packs.
Oh!
Play Link's classic 16-bit adventure.
And team up online to explore randomized dungeons in The Legend of Zelda A Link to the Past Four Swords.
I've never played Four Swords though.
I didn't have anyone to play it with.
Experience the remake of Samus' first adventure in Metroid Zero Mission.
Yeah!
Coming to the new Nintendo 64...
Switch.
...Nintendo Switch Online...
Mature.
Sure.
...17 -plus collection of games.
Mature.
Brave the dangerous lost land to stop the campaigners...
We were just talking about this game!
No way!
And...
Perfect Dark.
...to end their alien conspiracy in...
Now with online multiplayer.
I feel so targeted right now.
All four games will be available for Nintendo Switch Online...
Let's go!
...fantasy pack members later today.
I've been wanting to play Perfect Dark though for a while, so...
Set sail to save the day.
This guy...
This is Verona, a young woman with the ability to communicate with phantoms.
I will take all of this girl.
You sure now...
You are so cute.
I am an acquaintance of Zeyu.
So, from now on...
...to see Vanilla's aqualindre.
Even though I can't move her now...
...I can't move her now.
I am an acquaintance of Zeyu...
That's good.
You are still the best friend I had in the AM.
...you are still...
I never get into Disgaea because of that.
Or anything.
I'm just not a huge fan of turn-based stuff.
Which seems like it's totally my...
Oh my god.
Stop, they're so cute.
So cute!
Lots of Phantom stuff today too!
This is my Direct!
This is...
Oh no...
Oh no, what are we doing with Street Fighter?
Oh!
Wow!
That's a lot of games!
Fun!
The Punisher!
Oh wow!
Oh no!
Captain America is getting his eyes wiped!
Oh, that's cool!
I love stuff like that!
Oh, funky!
Funky!
Hold on, I'm gonna grab some tissues.
Oh no!
What?
Oh no.
Uh oh.
No.
Oh no.
A Super Mario Party Jamboree!
Oh no!
COCONUT MOLE!
Rainbow Galleria.
Oh my god.
Could other people...
Who was that guy that took the star?
Goomba Lagoon!
Oh my god, Luigi's about to die.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh god, no.
Oh!
Oh, look at all the boos and the...
Oh, the chain jump's so cute.
Oh god.
Battle of wits.
Okay.
Oh god.
There's a lot of people.
20 people!
This is too chaotic.
No way.
20 people!
That's too many!
Are you kidding me right now?
Oh my god.
This is so much fun.
I can't wait to see this.
Let me see...
How many times do I have to say this?
20 times!
I can't wait.
How many times do I have to say this?
I can't do it.
I can't.
This is going to be fun, but the games are probably too long, right?
Like, for it to be with viewers.
Zelda?
New Zel- wait.
Not new Zelda, but...
If it's a new 2D Zelda, though...
Oh my god!
It's like a...
I'll kill you next time!
Wait...
Actual Zelda game?
Wait, actual Zelda game?
No way...
Zelda Zelda game?
This is the year of the ladies, everybody!
First we get Peach...
And then we get Zelda Zelda!
They're gonna call it Link.
I love the little, like, dead Link on his shirt.
I love 2D Zelda!
Does this count as 2D Zelda?
It's like a little 3D.
Zelda real!
Okay...
HD 2D.
Yes, I'm very curious.
This is the last lands of Hyrule.
Strange rifts have appeared.
And have taken many people.
Oh my god!
Including Link.
Bye, Link.
Now, alone, Zelda meets the fairy, Tri.
Receives a mysterious staff called the Tri-Rod.
And sets off on a journey across Hyrule to save her kingdom.
Just try harder, Zelda!
By waving the Tri-Rod at a table she found, Zelda learned how to create an imitation of it, called an Echo.
Okay.
Once you learn an echo of something, you can recreate it whenever you'd like.
Oh, neat!
Even if there's a wall blocking your path, you can create echoes of tables to get a leg up.
Just like that.
Oh, cool!
You can create wooden boxes.
Old beds.
I can make a box!
And a bed!
How you use them separately or together is entirely up to you.
Oh my god, it's a Minecraft water tower.
Learn and create echoes of something.
You can create echoes of things you find while exploring Hyrule.
Whoa!
You might be surprised at what you discover.
There's so many combinations you can do.
What?
That's kind of cool!
Even battles will look different.
You could pick up and throw a rock echo, for example.
Oh damn!
That's not all, though.
You can also create echoes of monsters.
Oh my god, there was like a little tiny version of a...
After doing so, they'll bite by your side.
What?
Monsters have different abilities.
But what does it cost, right?
To choose the one you want to create, based on the situation.
Wisdom is key after all.
What does it cost to summon something?
Whoa!
Interesting.
I think it would still take me...
It would take me a minute to get used to this.
A Hyrule without Link?
The fate of the kingdom is now in your hands.
Oh my god!
How was that?
I hope you enjoyed this demonstration of the echo video...
That looks so fun, though.
...which channels Princess Zelda's wisdom.
They create deco trees, huh?
To be honest, I haven't...
They even have the little spiky guys!
How you solve puzzles and battle enemies will change depending on the echoes used.
In short, we've created a game where each player's experience will be different.
Yeah, everybody can...
You can play as you want!
The Legend of Zelda Echoes of Wisdom launches September 26th.
That's so fun!
A Nintendo Switch Lite system inspired by the Legend of Zelda series will also be available at launch.
Oh, it's pretty!
Isn't this just the Necromancer monkey?
Now, I'd like to return this moment I'd stolen away back to Mr. Takahashi.
Thank you, Mr. Aonuma.
How could you say that you stole it away?
You're Mr. Aonuma!
Aonuma-sama!
You're so legendary.
More headlines?
Is that what he said?
Uh-oh.
Sorry, I have to turn off the audio for this.
I don't want to get copyright struck.
Sorry.
It's K-pop, I think.
That looks like Lady Gaga.
Hot new tracks!
Ariana Grande!
See ya!
Green Day?
Oh yeah, there's Lady Gaga.
Oh, cool.
I've never played, actually, one of these games before.
But I've... have you guys...
Did you guys know that these are, like, real people?
That they just put in this makeup...
And then, like, put a filter on top?
Like, there's people...
The people that are dancing...
Actually...
Like, look like that.
They have, like, a bunch of face makeup and stuff on.
Oh, okay, we're good.
Lego!
I'm very curious about the Green Day dances.
Oh.
What?
Okay.
You're gonna climb up onto the cauldrons...
Climb up onto Tallnecks...
And traverse other locations inspired by the original game.
What?
But be careful.
Swarms of machines are lurking everywhere.
Okay.
Use an array of gadgets like blast boots and gravity bombs to hunt them down.
I never played the...
What was the game?
From the Nimble Watchers...
To Mighty Sawtooth.
Horizon...
What was it called?
You might even come across the fearsome Thunderjaw.
Oh, just Horizon?
As you progress, you can help Aloy rebuild your home.
Oh my god, cute.
I love this.
Hot dog!
Okay.
Interesting.
No, I saw a hot dog.
I saw it for real.
Stray!
This is another game I wanted to play, but didn't...
have a chance to.
Oh my god, little baby!
Oh no!
Don't just stand...
Oh my god, Simba!
My scar!
Mufasa!
Wait, was this not on the Switch before?
Lord, live the game.
So it was only PS4?
Oh, okay.
I'm just a cat!
Crazy.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, okay.
Neat!
Rude!
I know I'm short, but come on!
Hahaha!
I'll always be yours!
Animal Crossing Hobbit style!
There's a new color to the little haven of fire!
You'll befriend your neighbors, work together to solve problems, and even share a meal!
It's more, harder, fish, porridge, and cook!
I love how any time it's like customize your house, it's just like Animal Crossing!
The best way to build a Hobbit community is by hosting a dinner party with your homemade dishes!
Wow!
I can poison everybody!
Plus, you can threaten your neighbors for unique decorations or special interests.
Gandalf?
A Lord Of The Rings TM Game.
A Lord...
AAAAAAAAAAAA!
AAAAAAAAA!
No way!
As the Prolific Prosecutor miles up, take the case out of the courtroom and investigate crime scenes.
Check for information by interviewing people and inspecting evidence.
Let's go!
We can say we're scared!
Yeah!
Enjoy all new, hand-drawn character visuals from the original series' character designer.
Or swap to the original sprites for a more classic look.
Oh, fun!
Oh my god, I love when they do that.
Yeah!
Let's go!
You'll find character art, music, including orchestral arrangements, and more.
I'm so excited!
Past and present collide as you uncover the truth...
Yippee!
...at any cost.
Ace Attorney Investigations Collection launches on Nintendo Switch September 6th.
Yippee!
September!
So far for now!
Yippee!
Anime!
Oh no, Danganronpa?
Uh-oh.
I was like, yay, anime!
Oh no, Danganronpa!
I don't think it is, or is it?
I don't think it is, though.
I think it's just the same art style.
After a devastating attack by unknown assailants...
Oh no!
Takumi Samino's life gets turned upside down.
A mysterious school mascot suddenly appears.
Me?
You?
While Takumi manages to get out of harm's way, he's then forced to enroll at the Last Defense Academy, along with 15 other students.
I hate when I'm forced to go to school.
Oh, who's the girl behind him?
With the tongue out!
Who is her?
My neurons have been peaked.
Oh, there she is!
Ah!
Darumi.
Oh my god.
His brain.
Maybe that is not me.
Or you.
Danganronpa.
The what?
The...
Oh wait, I can't read it.
The what?
The...
What is the...
What does that say?
I can't read the font!
What?
I didn't hear what he said!
Oh, the hundred line!
Oh!
I'm sure there will be people excited about this.
Oh no!
Did someone mention the Door to Darkness?
A lot of remakes.
Yeah, a lot of remakes.
Yeah.
Oh!
What is up with these brainy creatures?
Every decision you make will dramatically alter the course of the story.
Haha!
Serves her right!
Why didn't you pick that, you coward?
Haha!
Serves her right!
Otherwise, the vengeful seven heroes may emerge victorious.
Harpy.
Romancing Saga 2 Revenge of the Seven launches on Nintendo Switch October 24th.
Haha!
Hahaha!
We hope you're excited to experience the full remake of Romancing Saga 2.
Oh my gosh, it's already almost been an hour.
That's almost everything for today's Nintendo Direct.
Uh-oh.
Tomodachi Life.
The next will be our last announcement.
Please take a look.
The last announcement, you guys!
I'm holding my breath!
No!
Wait, it could still be Tomodachi Life!
Hahaha!
It's Metroid.
Samus!
Tomodachi Life!
Come on, bait and switch us!
FPS?
FPS, Samus?
Interesting.
Space pirate.
Oh.
Nasty.
Hahaha!
Ooh!
Let's go!
One more trust.
2025.
Okay.
Next year, guys.
No Silksong?
No Tomodachi Life 2.
That was a first look at Metroid Prime 4 Beyond.
After a very long time, we are finally able to share more information about this title.
Release is planned for 2025, so please wait a little bit longer.
That's what he's telling everybody to...
Silksong?
Please wait a little bit longer.
That's all for today's Nintendo Direct.
Thank you for watching.
Thank you.
Ace Attorney!
That's all I'm thinking about right now.
That and the...
That and the new Zelda game.
Thank you for hosting this watch-along.
Thank you guys!
Thanks for joining.
Thanks for hanging out.
Sorry no Tomodachi Life, Minto.
It's okay.
Bye!
I hope people...
You know...
When they stop, or rather...
When they keep not announcing it...
The more watch-alongs we'll do.
The more watch-alongs we'll do!
Since we're just...
Holding out, maybe?
We didn't get skong...
But we got a new Zelda.
New Zelda looks interesting.
You're also pretty fun to me.
That's cool.
Anyway...
I didn't...
I'm not sure how I feel.
Like, I actually really like how you fight in Zelda and stuff, so not having my little sword and everything makes me a little sad, but we'll see.
It still looks interesting.
Mario Brotherhood?
Call it what it is, it was Brother Ship!
Don't erase the Brother Ship!
That's where the gumshoe can be your Tomodachi!
Stop!
Yeah, we have the tri... what was it?
The tri... the tri-hard... the tri-wand... the tri-fairy!
That was fun though.
Hold on, let me erase that.
Is there anything else?
Oh, it just says thank you for watching.
And it's over.
I'm looking at some of like the... thingies?
The... what's it called that you gave me?
The recommendations?
And right there, Silksong announcement trailer!
Five years ago!
Oh man...
Brother Ship.
Can't believe DoomStream manifested Turok.
I know, right?
That too!
We were literally just talking about it.
That's so funny.
I love watching these with you.
Thank you, Ruby!
Oh yeah, the Metal Slug Tower Defense!
It said it was gonna be available today, right?
I will be... I will be grabbing it.
I will be... downloading that.
I love Tower Defense.
That's a... I've wanted to play... isn't Arknights also Tower Defense?
But... I've heard it's really hard, so...
Silksong died so the Brother Ship could sail.
I got news, Ace Combat 7... not in the Direct.
But release on the Switch July 11th... wait, really?
Was that in the Jap... wait, what was in the Japanese Direct?
That we missed?
Wait, what was in the Japanese Direct?
Um... Japanese Nintendo Direct.
Maybe I should've watched the Japanese one.
Metal Slug TD is actually a mobile game that's getting ported.
Oh, really?
Oh, I see.
I see.
Uh...
Direct.
Maybe I should go to... hold on.
I wonder if she has a link.
I see Korone-san stream up.
So I'm just gonna... I wonder if she has... Oh, she does have it linked!
Yippee!
Thank you, Koro-san.
Um... I'm scrolling through...
What did they start with?
They started with...
Oh, Mega Man!
Hold on.
Let me, uh...
Let me get the window up.
Window capture.
Sorry, the cut's gonna be a little ugly, but...
Or the crop, rather.
There we go.
Let's see what we have.
What we missed in the Japanese one.
Mega Man!
Oh, sorry.
Rock Man.
Um...
Does the Japanese stream longer?
I don't think so.
Can make it a little bit bigger.
There we go.
We're not gonna watch the whole thing.
I'm just gonna skip through it.
Rock Man World 3!
Oh my god, my eyes.
I didn't know they had different things.
Yeah!
I'm skipping.
Is this the Brother Ship?
No!
Oh, sorry.
Oh, wait!
Stop, please!
Wait!
No, wait!
It was Paper Mario RPG!
What is this?
Wait, hold on, hold on.
I saw something else, though.
Oh, this fish game.
What the hell is this?
Fish.
Wait,
this hasn't even started.
Right.
When does it start?
Oh, maybe it has...
Oh, here's the actual direct.
I'm just going through advertisements at the moment.
Oh my gosh, I'm an idiot.
Sorry, guys.
I'm going through...
I just read the bottom.
It says it starts at 11.
That's what it says.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's my alarm.
Sorry.
Whoopsie.
There we go.
I'm looking at the fish, man.
I was excited about the fish.
Okay, we got the Brother Ship.
We got this same thing.
Oh, the Lego Horizons.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
That...
Dementia game.
Fantasian games.
Sports.
What is this?
Oh.
Metal Slug.
Oh, not Fairy Tail 3?
What is this?
There's always, like, one of those fashion games, you know?
Oh, Mickey Mouse.
I also...
It's also so curious why, like, the order's so different, too, you know?
Dragon Quest.
The Capcom.
What is this?
But there is a Fairy Tail 3.
Look at the little Wii's.
Morro!
KT!
You're welcome to the membership!
Thank you!
Oh, Monkey Ball.
No.
Butto Bird.
Not the Monkey Ball at all.
Yeah.
I want to Sugoshi...
What is this?
Wow.
Hot.
What is this?
Oh.
Perfect Dark.
I'm just kidding.
The mashing.
I'm skipping forward.
Fairy Tail.
Actual Fairy Tail.
Phantom.
Of course there's Power Pro!
It wouldn't be...
The...
Did you see that?ORA!
Final
Gear Vengeance!
Let's go!
It's Snake!
Oh my god, he's even in the three pose.
Let's go!
That's my little guy!
That's my little maker!
He will be released once we get the delta.
Oh, it just popped open.
Is he still in an egg?
Yeah!
It's the same little guy!
I knew that they were going to be in the...
Actually, I didn't know that they were going to be in the game.
Wait, so does that mean like Pyramid Head and Goemon and...
Yippee!
I'm so happy just to see him right there!
Skim!
Oh, it's so wet.
It's really...
Oh my god, Silksong!
They announced Silksong for the JP side, everybody!
What is this?
There's so much going on here.
Don't give us hope.
Ninja Slayer!
Reynatus?
Oh, here's a Mario Party.
Skip, skip, skip.
Legend of Zelda.
Stray.
Skip, skip, skip.
Super Mario Party Jamboree!
Oh, Dempa Men's.
Skip, skip.
What is this?
Fall Guys?
They're so round!
What is this?
The true Silksong is the friends we made on the road.
So true, Sebastian.
Enki Party!
I love that name!
Ikiari!
Sorry.
I'm so excited.
Look up, Shu!
Look how cute!
Wee!
Wee.
I said,
you are my best friend.
And remember, my Dolphin Friends.
A soul.
Remove them.
I am...
Good, oh god.
Oh, One Piece!
See, I feel like this could totally be announced for us too, right?
Anime.
One Piece is real.
The One Piece is real.
They totally glossed over it.
They were like, by the way, there's One Piece!
Just a deluxe edition of the game RPG.
Oh, the slime!
I almost said fairy tale again.
It's the slime!
Oh, Gundam!
Fairy tale 4!
Oh, rhythm game.
Looks a little slow though.
UMA MUSHIME MECHAN!
UMA MUSHIME!
When will we get our UMA MUSHIME?
Oh, Natsumon!
The audio station will start streaming after this stream ends.
I, um...
OK, not dangamonpa.
Skip, skip, skip.
Skip, skip, skip, skip, skip.
Skip, skip, skip, skip, skip, skip, skip.
Oh, sorry.
Skipped too far.
I got too excited.
Looks pretty ominous.
Wait, no, this is just the... this is the Saga, isn't it?
This is the Saga game, is it not?
Romancing Saga?
Yeah, yeah, my bad.
And then... Metroid.
And that's it.
Really?
Maybe there's some other stuff that I accidentally skipped over, but...
Not too much of a difference.
Luigi?
Brothership.
Yeah, like, they start... oh wait, no, this is the... okay, there's...
Not too much of a difference.
Just a little bit.
They didn't even have one of those, like, fashion games.
I'm so shocked.
Where is JP Funko?
They didn't do the Funko... the Funko Pop game!
Woohoo!
I can't believe we're getting Funko Pop game.
Well guys, that was, uh, direct.
Oh my...
No, there was some... there was some... a lot of... a lot... a lot of remakes, right?
JP doesn't get Freddy... Fazbear Funko game rip.
Rip indeed.
That was fun.
Yeah, that was fun!
Maybe you skipped Tomodachi Life 2.
Yeah, of course!
I can't believe the Funko Pop game is actually, like, it feels like it's rivaling Fortnite in terms of, like, you know, everybody...
Like, there's so many different collabs.
You could see so-and-so fight so-and-so.
Arigato, arigato.
Chuuu.
I remember once the JP direct announced a new Super Robot Wars game.
Big hype moment for me.
Thanks for the watch-along.
Thank you!
Yeah, a lot of ghosts in this direct.
A lot of phantom mention.
And of course...
What was this?
I skipped over it on accident earlier.
That looks a little spooky, though.
I'll never forget the one time I was, like, hoping for a new Fatal Frame.
And they did the direct while I was at work, so...
I was like...
Oh, it was right after...
Sanrio Crossing.
Very text-heavy horror game.
This part is terrifying!
And they look so happy about it!
They're like, woohoo!
We're almost gonna die!
For some reason, the stream just does not want to...
Look how tiny he is!
My little dog!
He's so cute!
He's the king number one, baby!
I can't believe Pompompurin got booted.
I think it's been, like, a decade since Pompompurin has not been in the top three.
And Pompompurin got top four.
He was fourth in this year's Sanrio ranking.
It's kinda crazy.
Pochako is number two, I believe?
Kuromi was three.
Um...
Pompompurin was...
Four.
I can't remember.
PhiloKitty was five, I think?
Why is it loading?
Okay, 53...
Oh, he's so cute!
He's so cute even when he's making witchcraft.
Love it.
Um...
Thanks for the streaming!
Going back to work!
Good luck with work!
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god.
It's not Higurashi.
So, this is a series.
I've never heard of it before, though.
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh, I said Higurashi.
Maybe I should have said Umineko.
Oh my goodness, the amount of text.
It's so cool, though.
They know the Hannin.
Oh, I wanna play!
But my Nihongo is not good.
Well, Umineko Mansion.
Let's go!
I mean, they're on an island.
Someone's dying, you know.
Mucho texto.
Cool.
Ever played Famicom Detective Club?
Not yet!
Not yet.
Sadly, this probably won't get translated.
The first two haven't!
Unless there's like a fan translation, but yeah.
Probably...
Probably not.
Play game, become Jozu.
The thing about those types of games is that since they're made for like a...
They're made for like, you know, an audience...
Like a mature audience.
So I'm just like...
Furigana doko?
Oh no.
Can't read.
I would have to like...
I would get very Jozu, probably.
But this is how...
But this is...
A long time ago...
I feel like a lot of people learn from visual novels and stuff.
I learned from Love Plus.
I learned a lot of stuff from Love Plus.
So...
And then I forgot it all.
But...
Yeah.
So...
A lot of people learn from visual novels, I feel like.
Love Plus mentioned...
A game will probably...
Never ever get again.
So sad.
Thanks for the pink!
Thanks for doing this watch-along.
Any games you're interested in streaming?
And streaming?
I don't know about that.
Maybe the Metroid game.
But I would want to play the other ones too, right?
Ronin, thank you!
Eternal Kamioshi.
Thank you so much!
But...
The Love Plus gacha died.
Love Plus everything died.
Arigato, arigato.
Chu!
Thank you, Ducky!
My wife gets released.
And some friends and I will be pulling for her.
May you bestow upon us your blessing...
On our firefly...
You would firefly, man.
Ooh, mint neko.
It's okay if you just bless mine.
I won't tell.
I bless...
You and your firefly pulls.
Moi moi.
Moi moi!
Pull.
Please.
I like firefly.
I think she's very cute.
Though I don't know anything about Honkai.
Can you curse them instead?
Coming from a ghost, it might be a curse instead of a blessing, right?
Would you recommend Love Plus for Japanese learning?
I think so.
I think I would.
Because it's always better to learn from something that's like a little bit more conversational, right?
Fun fact, when Umineko was releasing, it would take months for Ian to get a translated version.
There's software that would read the screen and translate the game.
Some of the oldest memes have come from that.
I've read three games that way.
Oh my gosh, Saku.
Your brain.
Well guys, this was fun!
Thanks again for joining me.
For watching the watch along.
The direct together.
What is this?
I guess Xenoblade X remake will have to wait for Switch 2.
Yeah, where's our Switch 2 announcement, huh?
Ace Combat 7 had already announced on Switch during January.
Ah, I see, I see.
The producer for Ace Combat franchise confirmed the release date today on Twitter.
Ah, got it, got it.
Nice.
I wonder how it'll play on the Switch though.
No wonder.
See you tonight for more Outer Wilds.
Yes, I will be streaming again tonight.
Outer Wilds.
So, short stream today.
But, for now.
Short stream for now.
And I might see some of you guys later for some more Outer Wilds.
And if not, then I'll see you maybe...
What am I playing tomorrow?
Playing Deal or No Deal tomorrow.
Yippee!
I just wanted to play Deal or No Deal.
For some reason.
I don't even know how to play that game.
But...
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you!
And...
Yeah.
I'm gonna go maybe take a nap.
Have fun with the Metal Slug game.
Thank you!
Yeah.
Maybe I'll stream that.
Maybe.
I don't know what to stream from...
Maybe Donkey Kong?
Hmm...
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Ace Attorney.
I should return to Ace Attorney, huh?
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Everybody...
I'm gonna go eat some breakfast too.
I'm hungry.
Otsumito, everybody!
Thanks for joining!
Thanks for hanging out!
Thanks for watching!
I hope there's some things that you guys are excited for.
And if not, there's always Next Direct!
Otsumito, guys!
See you guys!
Maybe see some of you later.
And if not...
See you when I see you!
Otsumito!
Itterashai!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
Itterashai-masu!
Master!
Lady!
Bye-bye!